i think we we just feel um
such a debt of gratitude to richard
radcliffe who has campaigned so
ceaselessly
um and i think he's the kind of person
who shows
politicians what they need to do
he's faced the most incredible adversity
i think it's also worth saying that
nazanin herself has been incredibly
brave and um
you know
the contacts i've had with her by
whatsapp you know i just see this
resolve and courage despite
this incredibly unfair situation of six
years of her life taken away by an evil
regime and jeremy did you have contact
with her after your foreign secretary
and what's that so have you kept up that
contact yes and i um
i have and you know i wasn't able to
secure a release when i was foreign so i
wanted to carry on doing everything i
could
after i stepped down um but i think
richard and nazanin between them have
done the most incredible favor to the
world because
until nazanin the world didn't know
about iran's hostage-taking
and the reason was because whichever
country it was uh the foreign ministry
would advise
uh the family of a hostage don't talk
about it we want to negotiate this in
private richard ignored that advice
including from the foreign office and he
said i'm going to tell the world what's
going on here and so it's not just about
naznen's release it may be that we can
bust open this scandal and put a stop to
it once and for all and jeremy
this has been a protracted battle as i
said you were a foreign secretary
dealing with this there's been five
foreign secretaries dealing with it
three prime ministers
why is it taken so long and why is now
the moment that nazanin and others have
finally been released well it shouldn't
have taken so long
and i think it was
you know if you want to know the reasons
i think it was because iran linked it to
the payment of a historic debt
um successive british governments felt
uneasy about
paying something that might be perceived
as a ransom of course it's not a ransom
it's a historic debt that we accept that
we owe iran
and then
when we decided which i think
happened during my time as foreign
secretary that yes we were going to pay
this debt
uh there was then the mechanics of how
you pay it when iran has sanctions and
the truth is that you know we're there
today today is a day of celebration but
when the dust settles i think we will
need to ask ourselves why did it take so
long to resolve this issue
as a result of which it's been six years
of nazanin's life well the labour party
did say in pmq's today that they wanted
a review into this case and how as you
said it took so long to
resolve would you would you agree with
that that this needs to have a review so
it never happens again well there are
always lessons that can be learned from
these kind of incidents i think the
biggest thing we need to do now
and i think the sanctions against russia
have shown that the west can act
together in a very concerted and
effective way when it wants to
is we need to work out a way with our
democratic allies to stamp out the
practice of hostage taking with a system
where if you take a hostage from one
country it's treated like you're taking
a costage from all of them
and the price is just made too high
because this is a 19th century practice
it has no place in the 21st century you
don't there needs to be a review you
just think lessons should be learned or
you do think that should be a review
well i mean it doesn't really matter
what you call it but we of course we
need to learn lessons from nazna's
particular case but the most important
thing
is to make the changes internationally
so that this hostage taking is stamped
out and and jeremy you said that the
money because you were foreign 2017 yeah
2018 2018
so that's four years ago and you said
that the money you'd kind of got the
agreement on the debt but it took four
more years is it literally paperwork i
mean it's it seems astonishing that it's
taken that long
were there mistakes by the government
over this
i don't know whether you can say there
were mistakes and i think today we have
to recognize that um you know liz trust
has painstakingly negotiated a deal that
have got two people out and one person
released from prison so i think it is a
day when you know we should recognize
that a lot of work by a lot of people
has led to the right outcome
but i think yes there are practical
difficulties there were sanctions
against iran but
why did it take so long of course people
want answers to those
what has changed that meant liz trusts
could
kind of close the negotiation that you
couldn't close four years ago because
you obviously were some way on the path
i mean what what changed was it the
government's approach changed or the
environment changed i think you have to
ask that question to liz trust because
she will be able to tell you exactly
what happened but i think there were all
sorts of factors like
the
reality that to pay this money
we had to have a waiver from the united
states because any bank used to pay the
money
would get sanctioned by the united
states would be unable to do business in
the united states so
whether that was the route that was
taken i don't know but there is a lot of
complexity
in sorting this out